hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
sonic mania is a nostalgic thrill ride
of 16-bit blender it's literally one
huge gigantic reference to previous
Sonic titles and 1990s culture is 40
Secrets Easter eggs and references that
we noticed and think you should too by
the way there's a few boss encounter
spoilers here so come back later if you
don't want to know them just yet okay
okay let's do this
starting on the title screen if you can
look past the logo then in the distance
you'll see the island Sonic mania begins
on and the evil item you will notice
it's the shape of Sonic space
[Music]
around the edge of the logo itself is
designed to look like Genesis or Mega
Drive directional pad decal pretty nice
touch
at the beginning of chemical plant zone
a seemingly random chemical lands on
Sonic's head
it seems out of place but after a little
digging the origins of Sonic shake dry
animation can be found it's a not so
subtle nod to Sonic Spinball a pinball
title from 1993 a sonic goes out of the
water at the beginning of the toxic
taste during act 2 of the chemical plant
sonic bumps into his old nemesis dr.
Robotnik and faces off in a strange
little minigame
this is a callback to dr. Robotnik's
mean bean machine from 1993 based on
another Sega game named by the way once
you unlock this you can play it anytime
you want against the AI are against the
friendly the sonic debug mode returned
in mania - allowing you to move about
the level like a developer and drop
random items and lives the great effect
[Music]
to use it simply start a new game and
highlight the no save option the
triangle button now gives you lovely
secret options such as the debug mode
this works in the same way on xbox but
switch users you'll be entering a code
for access to this one as a continuation
of all these secret options here you can
also activate Sonic's abilities from
previous Sonic titles but only if you
will lock them during the bonus stages
this can also change elements of Sonic
mania to resemble or mimic those in
numerous other sonic cycles oh by the
way the special stages in Sonic mania
are developed from the UFO hunting
stages in Sonic CD or the general
gameplay mechanics in Sonic R if you've
never played Sonic R it's a racing game
like Mario Kart but without as many
cards
[Music]
this is also the home of Andrew Nichols
mode which was and still is a meme which
causes people to add and knuckle to the
end of random things it actually
originates from a technology known as
lock-off it also comes with logon
technology allowing one sonic cartridge
to be physically connected to another if
it was done during Sonic 3 the player
would unlock Sonic the Hedgehog 3 &
Knuckles see see where I'm going it
allowed Knuckles the Echidna to play out
his on stages and contribute to the
entire storyline so the name is a
continuation of adding Knuckles to an
existing property strange but true
speaking of the lock-on technology there
are neon light in studio ah police that
reveal this groundbreaking technology
and again using the flip cards in the
same level little knobs to other Sega
franchises can be spotted around the
game - in studio ah police the pink box
sign may look familiar as it has a
striking resemblance to the pint pot
cafe in Streets of Rage 1 & 2
[Music]
travel a little further and sonic will
be beamed from an outdoor broadcast
truck which has some really a marking
the high-class sonic is a callback to
one of the main vehicles in Daytona USA
or should I say Daytona the transferring
sound effect is also from Sonic Spinball
coincidentally Sonic made an Easter Egg
appearance in Daytona as a rock
sculpture in a mountain no less back in
sonic mania and those screams that Sonic
passes are based on the Sega Game Gear
with the three color logo recreated to
perfection on the opening plane journey
tales can be seen wearing flight goggles
I expected them to be the same from sky
chasing sonic 2 but they were nowhere to
be seen
in fact I'm told they are from Sonic's
cartoon movie released back in 1999 I
guess though alternately if you decide
to play Sonic mania as tails Sonic will
wear his scuba goggles while piloting
the planes pretty cool yeah but the
goggles were designed to be in the
original Sonic title but were never used
they most probably would be used to
prevent Sonic from drowning underwater
speaking of removed content from the
original Sonic title during the press
Garden zone the jumping rabbit things
known as flaps are scattered around the
zone for you to destroy well the splats
were intended to be in the 90s sonic
games but were taken out before the
final release the same can be said for
Sonic's pose at the end of the stage
which was present in the early build of
Sonic 1 with a few extra elements from
very early concept art drawings this is
the same situation for the lamps in
Studio awfulest which were repurposed
alien UFOs that didn't make the cut all
those years ago
staying in Studio awfulest and the level
itself is a reference to the LA studio
of the same name which is you to do the
vio for english versions of Sonic the
Hedgehog dating back to 2010 no less did
you notice the horrible feedback drone
during the end of your time in studio
awfully
[Music]
this is a reference to the car crusher
livestream say you're made to celebrate
Sonic's 25th anniversary there's so much
information we wanted the entire
broadcast was ruined by the
aforementioned drone and made the event
a bit of a laughingstock even the date
on the screen is the same as the live
stream it's good to see Saiga seeing the
fully side of that disastrous live
stream unless they haven't found that
easter egg yet awkward that's the sound
of 25 years of Sonic well I hope it
comes down to 25 years of Sonic it's
more like tinnitus thinking in studio
Ovilus and the popcorn machine sonic
finds himself in this is a real thing in
Japan known as the Sega sonic popcorn
shop after selecting the popcorn of
choice a minigame is displayed allowing
the user to play whilst waiting for the
popcorn to be made dr. Robotnik would
attempt to prevent tails from making the
popcorn but don't worry too much it was
not possible to fail so you're
guaranteed to get your popcorn in many
flavors including curry flavor a nod to
Club Sega can be seen in the background
at Studio AA police club spin sounds
like a really good place for Sonic to
visit but Club Sega is the real
counterpart the club in billboard also
says ages underneath which is Sega
backwards and yet another nod to
old-school Sega and the advertisement
run to be this good take ages to be this
good tick Seger
Cerebus proved to be second another
Sager advertising campaign is also
referenced in mania and came at the time
when Sega and Nintendo ruled the video
game world turning over the cards like
an 80s game show we'll reveal Genesis
does this is a reference to the day when
Sega through shaheed at nintendo genesis
does what nintendo no sugar molecule
duty-free or color free what did pin
built ties with Sonic mania available on
the Nintendo switch this is probably as
far as the joke can be pushed without
causing effects turn another set of
cards over and you will find welcome to
the next level and pirate TV yet more 90
Sega advert which were a little off the
wall to say the least wasn't only new
action they did I say gotti rather
Speedway is a callback to Sonic CD not
only but during the boss fight with
Metal Sonic he calls upon the services
of another Sonic like being well that
silver sonic from Sonic 2 on the Master
System not the Mega Drive / Genesis he
was the end boss if you didn't collect
all the Chaos Emeralds back in 1991 in
the spring yard zone random words could
be seen in the background like cope up
on CPU if these were random words are
related to the games editor I'm not too
sure but they are back in Sonic mania
graffitied onto the side of trains or
subway vehicles in the background in the
metallic madness zone sonic can be
struck by a mysterious shrinking rain
the sprite he becomes looks like the
mini sonic from Sonic CD and arguably a
callback to the rearview mirror
decoration from rad 'mobile yet another
Sega video game if it's neither of those
then it'll be a reference to the
continue screen in many Sonic's titles
during the boss fight at the end of
Mirage saloon many of Sonic's old
friends and enemies turn up for a few
seconds nack the weasel shows up from
1994 sonic triple trouble as he appears
the sound effect from the game gear is
used lovely touch is the sound of sonic
losing his rings in all its 8-bit glory
in fact the polar bear who is best known
for being punched in the face by Sonic
is here - he's from Sonic the fighters
which was an attempt to turn Sonic into
a fighting game like Virtua Fighter it
didn't do too well that still a quality
reference being the dynamite is here -
and although he was in Sonic fighters he
is actually a character from the 1988
arcade and the game called dynamite
ducks were the next in which players
would be the south of different animals
in an attempt to rescue their girlfriend
Lucy speaking of girlfriends sonic
senpai screaming lady friend is in sonic
mania but not as a playable character
cheese reimagined as a remote-controlled
boxing during a fight with Robotnik on
metallic madness which could be a nod to
her size and stature in Sonic
aah or even the Amy dolls which were
scary as heck in Studio awfulest as a
reference to the Sonic Colors announcer
where the neon sign at the bottom will
say good great awesome as only amazing
complementing the player skill over in
the press garden zone is a boss name too
heavy ninja if you've played another
ninja themed Sega property from the 90s
the noises and sound effects may ring a
bell to you
[Music]
that's because many of them are taken
directly from shinobi what a quality
game Network does the jumping
caterpillar boss during x1 of Mirage
saloon look familiar
well it's a beefed-up version of the
caterpillar first seen in the original
Sonic 1 marble zone and the dangerous
belt our boss from sonic chaos is this
interspecies relations off steroid abuse
a cat Keyblade I'll let you decide so
there we go 40 sonic mania Easter eggs
and references in super quick time I've
tried to stay away from the references
that are only for hardcore fans in
favour of those which we can all
appreciate there are so many more
callbacks and references to discover and
if you found any please let us know I
will make a follow-up video and give you
a shout out for everything you uncover
first I'm Adam from Playstation grenades
this has been an absolute pleasure I'll
see you next time yay Jonah